hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational we
are returning to the match on each gear
reverse solid as a future future one
game one and now Giri with the white
pieces will do his best of course to
retaliate so let's see what happens in
Game two Giri opens with E 4 and we have
c6 by ELISA going for the caro-kann
defense we have d4 d5 and now II five
Giri goes for the advanced variation and
Bishop the f5 not not worrying about any
bayonets attack so nice to have three
Giri goes for the main line we have e 6
and now Bishop to e2 so now the pawn
chain has been finished and the bishop
is is out of its cage
we have Knight to e7 and c3 now
strengthening the center we have h6
if the ship is under attack you can
bring it all the way to h7 and the
castles here bye-bye Giri
we have Knight to d7 and now Knight B to
d2 we are a 5 preparing to start
expanding on the Queen side so white of
course prevents it with a 4 and now g5
Gary wants to now start an attack
against Gary's Kings since a Giri
already castled and fallujah may may
even Castle queenside in the future or
even Li leave the King in the center as
the center is closed so Knight the e1
there is one game where rook t1 was
played but after night to e 1 it is as
of move tender we have a completely new
game so Queen to c7 by Fallujah is
saying that maybe he will in fact Castle
queenside and now Bishop to age 5 Giri
keeps the King in the center as you need
to defend the f7 pawn so c5 starts
starts an attack on the center we have
f4 by Giri
and now C capture son d4 we have seek a
person before end Knight back to c6 and
Knight d2 f3 now just just going back
with the night helping out with the
defense of the d4 pawn G captures an f4
and Bishop captures an f4 so giving not
worried about opening up the G file for
ferocious rook and Bishop to e7
now fallujah says that he may in fact
Castle queenside even at the price of
the f7 pawn we have king - h1 by Gary
will be useful if the rooks come to
occupy the chief
and now if you lose your castles he
gives up the f7 point again
well the the the open G file for his
attack we have bunch of characters on f7
and now first rug detail faith kicking
back the bishop rush up to h5 and the
now King to b8 improving the safety of
his King first and rook the c1 so you
move the Queen you do not want to the
Queen on the same file as your rug Queen
to b6 go after the b2 pawn and now Queen
to d2 defending and here Queen to b3 now
going after the a4 point as well and
here you replace it Bishop captures on
h6 and it's it's quite a brave pawn grab
as you open up the H file for for
futures rook as well and you cannot move
the bishop since the bishop on h5 would
would will hang so it's definitely quite
a move if you Joe goes back Luke the c8
and now comes Knight back to G 1 we have
Bishop to b4 attacking the Queen and now
Queen moves Queen to f4 and now Queen
captures and b2 so just grabbing a pawn
and night e to F 3 again helping out
with the defense of the d4 pawn and here
Girish position is completely lost as
you could imagine after grabbing that h6
pawn grabbed engaged h6 1 is not the
mistake but everything together it just
allows the future for this really really
awesome move so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find this move for
future well I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
supporting that it is almost impossible
to defend the g-tube pawn and for those
if you just wanna enjoy the show it's
rook cg8 and now you are threatening
mate and there is no good way to defend
the g2 point you cannot lift any rooks
if you go something there is no way to
block it if you move this Bishop you
lose the h5 Bishop there's really
nothing to do here you cannot block with
this Bishop s g4 it is a defender twice
so you'd have to go for g3 and it seems
like you've defended but now comes a
bishop to e4 you pin the knight and the
next you're just gonna capture on d4 and
white
completely deteriorate so this was in
the position however a future missed it
and he played night to be sexy goes
after the a for pawn we have h3 and the
now comes Knight captures on a four so
future grabs another pawn and creates a
past a pawn we have brush up the g4 by
Geary and now we have captures captures
so better captures H captures and now
rook F the c8 kicking back the Queen of
course you want the Queen to get away
from the defense of the h6 bishop
so queen III only square they were left
for the Queen aside from g5 and now
Knight captures on d4 here a few juh
went for it a little bit too fast first
you move the rook you move the rook to
see it the g8 or wherever but here if it
went for Knight captures on d4 a bit too
quickly and it seems like he calculated
everything properly point is that at the
end of the variation you have Bishop to
d2 with an attack on the Queen and on
the bishop which will fall with check
however you don't because Knight
captures on d4 this is what give
replayed we have rook captures on f1 and
now rook captures on f1 and here Bishop
to b2 just going after this however
future missed one move when he captured
on d4 so feel free to find this move
while you pause the video and defend
this position for Gary while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on removing one of the attackers from
the bishop on h6 and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show its rook
to f8 check only move that says Geary
and Geary finds it so now the problem is
if you move the King for example King to
a7 this is just a very quick death
knight b5 a double double check from the
Queen and the night and after King a 697
is made as the knight and Queen cover D
squares and the Queen covers a 7 so that
would be very unfortunate and if you go
to c7 it's not much better a knight c6
check you're gonna go to d7 and now you
just get the Queen out of harm's way and
blacks King in the center of the board
is completely lost even if you grab the
bishop with check still doesn't help you
this is now a threat and there's there's
just not much to do a queen and rook
will mate to the black King even if you
capture here and then Queen F
check you have to move the King and
Queen f7 will be made as the pawn
controls d6 so really a difficult
position for future
so after Luka faith check of course not
going anywhere with the King rattle rook
captures on f8 but now giri can just
grab the bishop Queen captures as there
is no longer this pin so you do not lose
the Queen
so rogue back to a trade by future and
now Knight back to h3 not allowing the
pin to exist and Quinta a1 check future
still pushing this for a win king h2 and
now Knight back the c5 we have g5 now
giri starts pushing his passport and
knights the e4 now we have Quinta III
and now comes rook the g8 going after
putting pressure on the g5 pawn not
allowing it to be pushed to g6 and g7
and here unites the f4 by giri
we have a for Fallujah again starts
pushing vias passed pawn and here
grabbing this point is is definitely the
way to go but it both players are very
long time and it's a complicated
position so kiri instead goes for a
knight the c6 check he sacrifices the
night for for either a very weird
continuation of the game or just for a
nice perpetual for example if the point
is if the knight is captured then Queen
b6 check and you can just continue
checking the black King King goes here
check and then everything goes back you
continue checking if and if the King
goes here you might even want to choose
to go d7 check and capture this and
still continue to play this game or you
can just well happily continue to be
checking the white at the black King
however most likely result would be a
draw but Ali Reza doesn't want to draw
all it as it goes for king to c7 he
wants to continue this game and now a
Giri goes back Knights to d4 and now
Knight the b5 with check sorry first 83
fallujah starts pushing the pawn and now
Knight the b5 with check King to c6 and
now Knight captures on a3 so
unfortunately for future he also
blundered the a3 pawn with check Queen
captures on e5 now are putting a pin on
this night here but now Knight to c2
going for d4 and e4 which will threaten
the black king so King back to thee 7
and now tonight the d4 again putting
pressure on the e6 pawn
so of course Volusia defends it and now
g3 now the night can finally move with
Queen back to c7 and now Queen to b3
going for Queen to b3 also going for
Queen to b5 check which will put a lot
of pressure on the rook here so Knight
to d6 stopping that but now Knight to h5
going for Knight f6 check to fork the
king and the rook we have looked back to
a eight and now Knight to f6 check still
King to see it and now Queen III going
for the pawn you could have captured it
right away but Aguirre doesn't want to
rush anything and he also has his
passport which of course he wants to
push we look the a to check by a little
Alireza
and now King h3 we have Queen f7
preventing the pawn push but now Knight
captures on e6 and here Aguirre is just
a much better position wise and also a
regarding material he has a bishop and
the night for a look so tonight's the f5
attacking the Queen and the Queen to c5
with check King to be eight and now
Queen captures on d5 so grabbing yet
another pawn we looked at F to defending
the knight but now Knight to d7 with
check with King to c8 now comes Knight
the Beast sex with check forcing the
King back to b8 and now comes Queen to
d8 with check and it was in this
position animal fifty fact that Ali Reza
Fallujah resigned the game and onigiri
is back in the match equalizing in Game
two
so here you resign because after we move
the King King age seven you get 98 check
and now you either go here and get mated
with Queen to b6 or you go up the board
for example King gate but now 96 check
just wins the Queen
so that also works quite well for a for
Geary so really a weird game fallujah
did everything well he sacrificed the f7
pawn went for the attack the attack had
a win a few times I during the game but
then he really rushed it with the knight
character sandy for Geary found a
brilliant defense would rook to f8 check
and in the end Felicia did not want to
draw he wanted to really crush Gary in
Game two and pretty much wrap up the
match but in the end that that's why he
was the game but it's it's definitely
the right approach as he no longer can
qualify for the for the
she can no longer reach the top four so
why not why not play as as best as you
can and try try and win every game so
they're definitely the correct approach
so that's game two I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank Abdul Moxie
know Rajee Kirsten Carson courts Steven
Atkinson Chris Antley and Martin Fisher
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here think'll for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Magnusson Invitational
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day